[موسيقى]
يقول عالم الاجتماع علي الوردي انظر الى
الاشخاص الذين يقدرهم المجتمع لتعرف
الاتجاه الحضاريه السائد في ذلك المجتمع
ولتتلمس مصيره وفق هذه القاعده نصبح عربيا
خارج التاريخ اذا نظرنا الى وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي من هم الاكثر متابعه فيها
الادباء ام السفهاء العلماء ام العرافون
الحكماء ام الفنانون الى العناوين
تصالحت السعوديه وايران فهل تصفدوا شياطين
الفتنه
مجزره في كنيسه لشهود يهوى بالمانيا
والقاتل مختل اسمه فيليب
غوتيريس عداله القران سبقت قوانين الامم
المتحده بقرون هل يوجد اخوان في تركيا حزب
اربكان ينتقم من اردوغان
قيس سعيد رجل الحل الاول في تونس والعالم
العربي
لحوم الحمير تعبر الحدود العربيه وتصل الى
موائد الجزائريين
دمرت عائلتين بالسحر ثم تسال عن حرمه قرض
ربويه لتمويل الساحر
مرحبا الثامنه ثابته نتحدث عن سنوات
القطيعه بين السعوديه وايران فبعد سبع
سنوات من الصيام عن الكلام المباح
والتواصل المتاح افطر الطرفان على تمر
سعودي وزعفران ايراني في طبق صيني يؤمل ان
يكون من البضاعه التي تدوم فالبرجر
الامريكي فيه من الشحوم والدهون ما يتقن
القلوب والامعاء بوصفه حديثه
لاخصائي التغذيه بعض اعوام من القطيعه شبه
التامه بين السعوديه وايران انتهت الجمعه
ببساطه صينيه بعدما اعلن البلدان استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه واعاده فتح سفرتيهما
وفقا لبيان مشترك البيان الثلاثي السعودي
والايراني والصيني قال علنا ان مبادره
الرئيس الصيني هي التي دفعت الى ولاده
الاتفاق الذي يت او تاكيد السعوديه وايران
على احترام سيادتهما وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه لكليهما هذا الافطار
الجامع على الصلح ياتي عشيه رمضان وقد يرى
الطرفان معا هذا العام هلالا واحدا يصومون
عليه وبكل الاحوال في رمضان تصفد الفتنه
فهل يدخل نتنياهو وحكومته في اجازه جبريه
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاسبق
نفتالي بناتنا عوده العلق بين السعوديه
وايران هو فشل لحكومه رئيس الوزراء بنينه
نياهو واضاف بلدنا هذه الخطوه تعتبر نجاحا
للدبلوماسيه الايرانيه وتمثل خطرا لدوله
اسرائيل كما انها تمس بشكل كبير في
المساعد بناء الائتلاف الاقليمي ضد طهران
العنف الديني ضد المصلين داخل الكنائس في
مشهد جديد يسجل في مدينه هامبورج شمال
المانيا بقتل سفاح ثمانيه اشخاص بينهم
امراه حامل من اتباع كنيسه طائفه شهود
يهوه وقد انتحر القاتل الذي سارع القضاء
الالماني الى نفي تهمه الارهاب عنه علما
ان اسمه فيليب لا علي ولا محمود وهو كان
من طائفه شهود يهوه وانشق عنها المدعي
العام الالماني اعلن اليوم ان منفذ هجومي
هامبورج شاب الماني في الخامسه والثلاثين
من العمر المدعي اوضح ان الشاب الذي هاجم
خلال الليله الماضيه كنيسه لجهود يهودا
كان سابقا من اتباع هذه الحركه ويملك رخصه
لحمل السلاح الادعاء رجح ان يكون المهاجم
مصابا بمرض نفسي ط شهودي يهوى التي يفوق
عدد اتباعها ثمانيه ملايين انسان حول
العالم تعرف عن نفسها على مواقعها الرسميه
على انها الطائفه المسيحيه الناجيه وتعتبر
انها الوريثه الاصليه للدين المسيحي لكن
الكنائس المسيحيه الاخرى على اختلافها
تحذر من شهود يهوى وتامر باقصائها اينما
وجدت
القهوه بيلفوا في المنطقه عندنا الفتره دي
وبيلفوا على البيوت بتاعه
منطقه لورانو وكده فعايزه احذركم من من
عملهم ومن دخولهم البيت زي ما جه في رساله
يوحنا الثالثه كده ان هو المفروض ان احنا
نسلم عليهم ولا ندخلهم البيوت احنا عندنا
يعني الانجيل بيقول لنا كده هل هذا الموقف
للكاهن المصري فردي كلا سؤال وجه سابقا
لباب الاقباط الراحل شنوده ابرز الرجال
الدين المسيحيين المعاصرين المشرقين على
الاطلاق سئل شنوده هل شهوده يهوى مسيحيون
فاجاب بدون تردد كلا فمن لا يؤمن بالعقيده
المسيحيه يكون كافرا بها
ليسوا مسيحيين
لان المسيحيه تقتضي الايمان بالثالوث
القدوس
وبلاهوت الابن ولهوت الروح القدس
وهم لا يؤمنون بشيء من هذا كله كراهيه
الاسلام سم قاتل فلا تتجرعوه ينصح الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش الذي
تحدث عن الربط الطبيعي بين الاسلام
والسلام للعنف والارهاب فجوتيريس كما يعلق
مؤرخ عربي يعلم كغيره اليس المسلمون من
صنعوا اسلحه الدمار الشامل العمياء
وترسانات الابادات النوويه الفلكيه وليس
المسلمون من ازهقوا عشرات ملايين الانفس
في حربين عالميتين وثالثه على الطريق
ولناقه لمسلم في اشعالها ولا جمل وليس
المسلمون من ابادوا ربع القاره الاوروبيه
في حرب مذهبيه وليس المسلمون من يحتفظون
بجماجم ضحاياهم من الذين قاموا الاحتلالات
في الجزائر وغيرها
انطونيو غوتيريس منصف في هذا الكلام
الامين العام للامم المتحده استشهد بايه
قرانيه ليخلص الى ان القران الكريم قد وضع
سرعه لحمايه اللاجئين قبل الامم المتحده
بعده قرون
قتل ثلاثه من افراد مجموعه ارهابيه
هندوسيه رجلا مسلما بعد الاشتباه بحيازته
لحم ابقار وقد القت الشرطه الهنديه القبض
عليهم فيما تنشطوا كالعاده دوائر المنظمات
الارهابيه للدفاع عنهم عيدوا الالوان طقس
هندوسي احتفالي ينثر فيه المتدينون
الهندوس الالوان على الطرقات
المناسبه هذا العام في ظل حكم حزب بهارات
يا جنات الدينيه المتشدد حملت معها
اعتداءات على الفتيات المسلمات في الشوارع
بترهيبهن واهانتهن ونزع الحجابات عنهن
ورشيهن بالاصبغه الملونه يحدث ذلك دائما
على مرء من قوات الشرطه في المقابل اوضعوا
الهندوس في الخليج افضل باصوات فلكيه من
اوضاع الهنود المسلمين داخل بلدهم الهند
مهرجان الالوان الهندوسيه عاشته الجاليه
الهنديه في البحرين والامارات بكامل طقوسه
دون ان يعتدي احد على نسائهم كما يفعلوا
متطرفوهم مع مواطناتهم المسلمات في الهند
[موسيقى]
وقع الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مرسوما
جمهوريا بتقديم موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الى الرابع عشر من ايار مايو المقبل ويبدو
اردوغان اكثر حماسه بخوض هذه الانتخابات
بعد اختيار احزاب المعارضه السته رئيس
اكبرها حزب الشعب الجمهوري العلماني
الاتتركي كمال كليتش دار اوغلو الذي ما
خاض انتخابات رئاسيه الا وخسر
اتضح اخيرا غريم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
بعد مخاض عسير اتفقت المعارضه التركيه على
ترشيح زعيمها كمال كلش داروكلو ما علاقه
بايران وببشار الاسد وهل صحيح انه يرى
ضروره انضمام تركيا الى محور الممانعه فهو
ابن عائله من الطائفه العلويه هاجرت من
خرسانه في ايران الى مدينه تونيج للشرق
التركيه التي تضم اغلبيه كرديه علويه يوصف
كما الاوغلو بانه حليف الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد في تركيا كما تشكل العلاقه التي
تربطه بارانا حاله من الغموض حيث سبق ان
صرح مدافعا عن طهران ضد اردوغان وانه كلا
من ايرانه وتركيا وسوريا والعراق يجب ان
تعمل سويا للتصدي لاي مشروع خارجي يحاول
التدخل فيه رئيس حزب السعاده الاسلاميه
تماال كرمولا اوغلو احد اطراف الطاوله
السداسيه حرص الى جانب زميليه المنشقين عن
حزب العداله والتنميه علي بابا جان واحمد
داوود اوغلو حرص على ان يعلن بنفسه ومن
مقر حزبه الاسلامي عن قرار المعارضه ترشيح
زعيم العلمانيه التركيه المتشدده كليتش
دار اوغلو المناهض للانفتاح على العالم
الاسلامي والداعي الى التقارب مع النظام
السوري ومع اسرائيل كما يوصف في اوساط
تركيه
[موسيقى]
حزب السعاده التركيه انبثق عام 2001 عن
حزب الفضيله الاسلامي الذي حلته السلطات
التركيه في حينه وهو بحسب الجزيره نت يسير
على منهج
التاريخي نجم الدين اربكان اربكان الذي
يصفه الموقع الرسمي لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين بانه فارس العلم والسياسه يؤكد
العديد من قيادات الاخوان اليوم في
تغريداتهم الحديثه في تويتر وفيسبوك
يؤكدون ان ليس له اي علاقه بالاخوان ولا
يوجد اصلا جماعه اخوان في تركيا يقولون
فماذا يقول حمزه زوبع المتحدث السابق باسم
حزب الحريه والعداله المصريه التابع
للاخوان ماذا يقول في برنامجه التلفزيوني
عن نجم الدين اربكان وعن حزب السعاده الذي
خلفه في زعامته تلميذه تمال كرمولا اوغلو
يوم الاثنين قلت ان حزب السعاده هو حزب
الاخوان فلازم تقول لك لا هو مش حزب
الاخوان ولا
الاخوان التنظيم هنا
كان بيقولوا الاستاذ نجم الدين
ما كانش في حاجه اسمها تنظيم اخواني كان
في الحزب طبعا الرفاه وهو رجل من افضل
اساتذه المربين لرئيسي حزب السعاده
الاسلاميه كرامولا اوغلو اكان اخوان او مش
اخوان لهم اخذ شخصيه ومسلكيه على الرئيس
اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه فيتهم
بالفساد والغدر واستغلال الدين من اجل
المصالح بل يتوعدوا اردوغان
بمقاضاته امام الله تعالى يوم الحساب
محافظه شارليك
ديانته
حزب السعاده الاسلامي الذي شهد انشقاقا
قبل ايام بسبب ترشيح كليتش دار اوغلو
لرئاسه الجمهوريه هاجمه ناشط مؤيد
لاردوغان لان الحزب بحسب قوله سامح اللصوص
والمستهزئين بالاسلام
الصادرين لحريه العبادات ولم يسامحوا
اردوغان ايربا كانوجايا الله
[موسيقى]
ان الفكره الامبرياليه الاستعماري
المناهضه لنهضه الشعوب القلبيه من كبواتها
والتي ترى بعين واحده وتكيل بمكيالين
وتقيس بثلاثه موازين
وتتقمص اربعه وجوه يدعي ان سوريا تحتل اخر
درجه عالميا على مؤشر الحريه احتلت سوريا
قائمه اسوا الاسوا على مؤشر الحريات في
العالم لعام 2023 ذلك بحسب تقرير لمنظمه
فريدوم هاوس الامريكيه غير الحكوميه
الوقايه المنظمه في تقريرها عن سوريا ان
الحقوق السياسيه والحريات المدنيه في
سوريا تتعرض لخطر شديد من قبل اكثر
الانظمه القمعيه
في العالم هذه اللحظه لحظه اعلان سوريا في
درك قائمه الحريات كان ينتظرها حاكم تونس
الاوحد قيس سعيد ليعلن بعدها عن نيته
استئناف العلاقات مع النظام السوري فهل
تقبل دمشق ربما يكون لديها شروط تتعلق
بتحسين مستوى الحريات في تونس ليس هنالك
ما يبرر ان لا يكون هنالك سفير لتونس لدى
دمشق واسفير للجمهوريه العربيه السوريه
لدى توريس هذا ما اكده رئيس الجمهوريه قيس
سعيد
مع الدوله السوريه اما اختيارات الشعب
السوري فهي اختياراته ولا دخل لنا فيها
اطلاقا حيث سعيد ومن باب الرفض اعاد فتحه
قديمه تستهدف تقسيم سوريا على اساس طائفي
علما ان العالم السياسي والاعلاميه برمته
سحبها من التداول وهذه
في الواقع تذكرنا بما يحصل اليوم في سنه
1920 تتعلق باحداث دوله حرب ودوله دمشق
ومنطقه الدروز ودوله للعلويين الى اخر ذلك
تؤيده او تعارضه هذا حقك لكنك لا تستطيع
ان تنكر ان قيس سعيد هو رجل الحل نعم هو
رجل الحل الذي حل كل السلطات والهيئات
الدستوريه في تونس فيما الازمات هناك عصيه
على الحل جديد المحاليل كل المجالس
البلديه في تونس خطوه جديده اعلنها الرئيس
قيس سعيد تندرج في سياق مشروعه السياسي
الذي يرمي للقطيعه مع المؤسسات السياسيه
المنتخبه خلال الفتره التي سبقت الاجراءات
التي اتخذها في يونيو 2021
سعيد اعلن خلال اجتماع لمجلس الوزراء انه
سيتم حل المجالس البلديه كلها
اخر
يتعلق
بحل المجالس البلديه كلها وتعويضها
نيابات خصوصيه حتى برلمان العشره بالمئه
من الناخبين الذي جاء على صورته في
الانتخابات المقاطعه شعبيا هدده سعيد في
جلسه الافتتاح بحله عند اللزوم وقد اثبت
سعيد في الاقالات الوزاريه الاخيره انه
عادل بين الخصوب والاصدقاء فهو يقصي
الجميع بدون تمييز واليوم على النواب في
جلستهم
الافتتاحيه وهذه
اعطاء فلوس ولا قرب باش نعمل كتله ولا قرب
باش نعمل قسمه
ينتبهوا وان الشعب وان الناخبين قادرين
على السحب الثقه منهم بعد سنه
تقول القصيده العربيه الشهيره للشاعر فخر
البارودي في مطلعها بلاد العرب اوطاني من
الشام لبغداد ومن مصر الى يمن الى نجد
فتطواني انشدناها حول الوطن العربي الكبير
فتيادا وشبابا في المدرسه والشبيبه
والكشافه واليوم كبرنا ولم توحدنا السياسه
لكن الحمير وحدتنا فصارت حمير بلا حدود
كبرنا وكبرت معنا مواشينا فتحولت الضان
الخروف الى حمار مع قله المال وكثره
السؤال
وبدنا ننشد وداعا لحمه الضان فما عدت
لاوطاني وان ذئبا قضى امرا تغدى كل خرفان
ومن حماره نضجت اولم لكل خلاني
فبعد الكشف سابقا عن تناول اللبنانيين
لحوم الحمير المهربه في بعض المتاجر وما
نشرته وسائل اعلام سوريه عن حالات تسمم
عديده نتجت عن تناول مواطنين وجبات لحوم
في بعض مطاعم دمشق التي تبين انها تذبح
الحمير وتطعم لحومها للزبائن اتت المفاجاه
الجديده من الجزائر مع انكشاف مذبح سري
للحمير اعد لبيع لحومها للاستهلاك خلال
شهر رمضان المبارك اين تم العثور على كميه
معتبره من لحم لحيوان الحديث الذبح بعد
المعاينه من طرف طبيب البيطري تابع
لمديريه المصالح الفلاحيه تبين ان هذه
اللحوم والاحشاء فاسده تخص حيوان من فصيله
الاحصنه نحن الحمير مع انعدام ادرى شروط
النظافه وفي العراق تقرير تلفزيوني سبق
تعقب الحمير المفقوده في الشوارع فاذ بها
قد تحولت الى وجبات ساخنه على موائد
العراقيين اسباب الاختفاء لا تصنف ضمن
الحيوانات المعرضه للانقراض وانما اختفى
وهو يقدم كاطباق تقدم لعامه الناس دون
علمهم يلزم يذبح وينطيه حمير حشاك في مصر
دائما هناك مؤيد لاي شيء فحتى الحمير التي
ضبطت لحومها عند جزار اسيوي في مدينه
المنصوره صار لها انصار ووجدت من يؤيد
اكلها بل التحريض على تناولها من متربعين
على كراسي المشيخه والاعلام المذيع تامر
امين يدعو الى التكامل مع الحمير غذائيا
وخالد الجندي في فتوى سابقه يجيز اكل
الكلاب عم تحكيني بالحمير
تستفزوه اكثر اما الحمير المخطط
مثل البقلاوه عند خالد بيتباع ويؤكل في
دول كثير من العالم عايزنا ناكل لحم حمير
شفتوا كلام الناس العاقلين طب لو ده حصل
يا ابو التمامير هنشوف امثالك بعدها فين
الحمار نفسه غالي جدا يبقى اذا الحمار
المخطط يجوز اكله هو احنا ليه ما بناكلش
لحمه حصانات اكل لحم الكلاب جائز لانها
طاهره
[موسيقى]
حكايه الختام من الغرائب التي حدثت هذا
الاسبوع على احد التلفزيونات المصريه
امراه متزوجه تبادلت العشق الممنوع
والخيانه الزوجيه مع رجل غريب فذهبت الى
احد المشعوذين لتطلب منه سحرا يؤدي الى
زواجها من العشيق بعد طلاق كل منهما فتم
الامر واعتقدت انه بالسحر لكن زوجها
الجديد طلقها بعد سنتين وعدا الى ام
اولاده
فقصدت المتيمه المخدوره
المسعوذه ثانيه ليقول لها الحل عندي لا
تقلقي لكن عليك ان تدفعي هذه المره مبلغا
كبيرا لا تملكه فهل تطلبه من قرض ربوي
مصرفي
الامراه تتحرى الحلال والحرام فاتصلت على
برنامج فتاوى ليس لتسال الشيخ عن طريق
التوبه من الخيانه وتدمير اسرتين والتعامل
بالسحر والشعوذه والدجل والكذب بل لتستفتي
الشيخ هل يجوز لها في شرع الله ان تاخذ
قرضا ربويا لتدفع به المال
للمشعوذ طمعا بجوله ثانيه من الخيانه
وتخريب البيوت لينطبق عليها المثل الشهير
البده طاهر والى اللقاء
بحب واحد وكنت متجوزه معلش كان متجوز رحت
الشيخ وقال لي اعمل لك قلب واخذيه يحبك
وهاخذ مني 10,000 جنيه وفعلا اديته عشره
الاف وطلق مراته واتجوزني لا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله
وعش يعني احلى سنتين في حياتي وخلفته منه
بنت وبعدين معاملته اتغيرت معي وسابني
ورجع لمراته الاولانيه وعرفت انها راحت
لنفس الشيخ ولما رحت للشيخ قال لي ده شغلي
واكل عيشي بس انا عادي ممكن ارجعه لك بس
تاخد منه منك 30,000 ما هو انا مش معايا
الفلوس فقلت اخد قرض بس في ناس اخذ قرض
في ناس بتقول ان القرض حرام بس لو حاجه
ضروريه مش حرام الله يصلح حالنا وحالك يا
بنتي ما بني على باطل فهو باطل
انا بس
كنت فانا هروح اعمل القرض عشان اديهم له
ولا ولا استنى بعد رمضان ولا اعمل ايه انت
بتتكلمي بجد انت بجد طب شكرا يا ايه
[موسيقى]